herr kubicki hat ja zu recht hingewiesen
auch unser straf und
ordnungswidrigkeitsverfahren sehr viele
pflichten unserem jeden von uns und
nicht jede pflicht wird zu 100 prozent
kontrolliert also der zwang macht auch
sinn auch wenn es an den landgrenzen
jetzt keine lückenlose hundertprozentige
kontrolle wird gebe ich muss ich muss
einmal auch mal schützen also wir werden
in der bekämpfung der pandemie in
deutschland nicht zu china werden wo die
leute mit drohnen überwacht werden oder
wo dann ihre häuser zugenagelt werden da
jetzt nicht rauskommt das würde unter
der geltung des grundgesetzes nicht
geben wir wollen auch gar nicht so genau
werden wir wollen kein polizeistaat
werden wie es ein landsberger auch
richtigerweise gesagt hat und ich glaube
dass eben der kurs den wir in den
letzten fünf monaten gefahren sind so
schlecht nicht da und wenn wir den auch
mit der ernsthaftigkeit mit der
seriosität aber auch mit der
eigenverantwortung der bürger so weiter
fortfahren
dann bin ich gar nicht so pessimistisch
das ist wie gesagt kein kurzstreckenlauf
sondern das wird uns noch immer monate
auch weit ins nächste jahr hinein
beschäftigen
aber trotzdem glaube ich ist dieser kurs
allemal akzeptabel und auch besser wird
auch besser nachvollzogen von der
bevölkerung wenn man hier nicht mit den
mitteln des des polizeistaats exekutiert